Now, Hunter Biden said
that his father didn't do anything wrong
and that Joe Biden never benefited
financially from his business dealings.
And here's the truth.
Legal scholars
and even Republicans have agreed to this.
They have agreed
that there has been no evidence
put forth of wrongdoing by the president.
The facts haven't taken me to that point
where I can say
that the president is guilty of anything.
I don't know that
you gonna see a high crime
or misdemeanor.
We don't have the evidence now,
but we may find it later.
So they say that they have no evidence,
and yet every single Republican
in the House of Representatives,
221 people, every single Republican,
221 people
without evidence voted to launch
an impeachment
inquiry, an inquiry
that is designed to distract
from the mounting evidence in the case
involving Trump's efforts
to overturn the 2020 election.
In fact, tonight,
we have exclusive new audio
of a December 2020
Oval Office meeting with then
President Trump.
pro-Trump attorney
Kenneth Cesaro
is telling Michigan prosecutors
that at the meeting
he told Trump how he could still win
using so-called alternate electors.
Listen to this part.
So I ended up explaining
that Arizona was still
hypothetically possible
because the also electors had voted.
And I explained the whole logic
We had more time with the allegation.
Of course, Trump embraced
Cesaro's theory,
continuing to falsely claim
that he won the election,
even though now we know person
after person of experts
sat the Oval Office
and told him that he'd lost
and that he accepted that.
Cesaro, of course, is an unindicted
coconspirator in Trump's
federal case as well.
We're going to get to much more
of that exclusive audio in a moment.
But first,
I want to get to Manu Raju on Capitol
Hill on the impeachment vote
that just passed.
Manu, that vote just happened,
as I emphasized.
Every single Republican supported it.
You've been talking to some of them.
What are they telling you?
Yeah, a lot of them supported it
because they said
the investigation should continue.
But I pressed a number of them
about whether they believe
that President Biden
should actually be impeached.
He would just be the fourth
president in American history
to be charged with high crimes
and misdemeanors.
An incredibly high bar to me.
And a lot of those members
I talked to are saying they have not yet
met that bar in fact, that, frankly,
they say that the impeachment inquiry
needs to gather the evidence
that they're searching
for, tying
Joe Biden, accusing Joe
Biden of taking direct action
to benefit his son's businesses
while the president
for the president was in office
as vice president.
They don't have that drug link yet.
But a lot of these members are hoping
that they can find that evidence
so they could support impeachment,
the impeachment, ultimately.
Now, some of those members
come from swing districts
and they are indicating to me,
yes, they'll vote now
to move forward on this inquiry.
But whether they vote to impeach him
is another question.
All right.
You ready to go as
far as impeaching the president?
No, I'm going to let the committees
continue their work,
develop their articles.
If they develop articles of impeachment,
show the show their evidence,
and then we'll make a separate choice
there.
How close are you to being ready
to support
impeachment, actual
impeachment of the president?
We're not there.
We we voted tonight
to allow for the investigation
to continue.
This was a vote to authorize
the investigation formally
because the White House
has taken the position
that it was an informal inquiry
and they didn't need to comply.
And this is going to put Speaker Johnson
in a bind in the weeks ahead
because a number of members on his right
are pushing for impeachment
of the president of the United States.
But some of those swing
district members that you heard
there are still
waiting for this investigation
to gather
even more information to prove
that Joe Biden acted corruptly.
Then they said they can charge him
with those high crimes and misdemeanors.
So, Aaron,
you can see the bind, given that
Mike Johnson
can only afford to lose three
Republican votes
on any straight party line vote,
whether he can get there
remains a huge question.
All right, Manu,
thank you very much on Capitol Hill.
Of course, speaking to those congressmen.
And I want to go now
to the Democratic Congressman
Ro Khanna of California.
He's on the committee that Hunter
Biden, Biden, defiantly
refuse to appear before today. Right.
Saying that he wanted to testify
publicly in front of in
front of everyone.
So, Congressman,
the impeachment inquiry is now
a done deal out of the committee.
Are you prepared
for televised
impeachment hearings, accusations
and everything else
that this investigation
will likely entail in an election year?
Urn, it's very sad because
the American people want us focused
on the cost of living.
The housing affordability
crisis is a total distraction.
I think actually is going to backfire
on the Republicans.
You saw
impeachment hearings in the past
have actually benefited
the person, the president.
And I think this is
not just a waste of time.
It's politically damaging for them.
So your colleague, Ken Buck,
the one Republican
who had expressed hesitation
about voting for the impeachment,
he was hesitant,
but he ultimately did vote for it,
as he said they all did.
When I spoke with him
on Monday, Congressman,
he criticized the White House
for saying
that it would not hand over records
unless they were forced to do
so by an impeachment proceeding. Right.
This whole point that, well,
this is informal,
We haven't been subpoenaed.
We're not going to hand
over the documents.
So Hunter Biden
today, then congressman, referenced
financial records
in his defiant press conference
very specifically.
And I wanted to play
one thing that he said.
James Colmer,
Jim Jordan,
Jason Smith and their colleagues
have distorted the facts
by cherry picking lines
from a bank statement,
manipulating texts.
I sent
editing the testimony of my friends
and former business partners
and misstating personal information
that was stolen from me.
Now, Congressman,
kind of all of this is true
as Hunter Biden lays it out.
Why won't the White House and Hunter
Biden just hand over the records?
Because, you know,
so they can't just cherry pick. Right.
Put them all out there.
If that would absolve themselves
of these accusations,
because there's no evidence or allegation
that the president has done anything
even slightly wrong in his role
as president.
This has been litigated
for five years and it's
rich for the Republicans
to be demanding all this release
of personal financial information
when they're leading candidate
Donald Trump doesn't
even release his taxes.
Joe Biden has provided
far more financial information
than anything Biden has.
This is a witch hunt.
And here's what I haven't heard.
I haven't heard the Republicans
say what has President Biden
since he's been president done wrong?
That's why you impeach someone.
So Chairman Jordan
on the committee write,
your chairman, Jim Jordan,
focused on something Hunter
Biden said at his press conference,
which is that his father
wasn't, quote, financially involved in
Hunter's business.
I just played that part of what he said
a few moments ago,
but he said he wasn't financially,
that there was no
he was not financially involved.
And Jordan says that
that's significant, that this shows
the story is shifting.
He says first,
President Biden had no involvement
at all in Hunter's business.
Now it's just no financial involvement
in Hunter's business. Do you
support the chairman's
focus on now
the use of the adjective financially?
I just don't understand
what all this is about.
If they want to make this case
in a campaign, fine.
Everything President
Biden has done since kindergarten
can be litigated in a campaign.
And they've been doing this
for the past five years.
But you can't impeach a sitting
president of the United States
for conduct That was years ago.
First of all, there's no evidence
that he did anything wrong.
But it's
they're going
after things that he did
potentially as vice president.
I mean,
can you imagine
if the Democrats had said,
we're going to impeach Donald Trump
for all the bad things he did
before he became president?
We focused on action
while he was president,
and they have not even had an allegation
that this president has done
anything wrong since he's been in office.
All right.
Congressman Cohen,
I appreciate your time. Thank you.